Each year, 40 million students graduate
high school and make what many consider
the most important decision of one’s
entire life: where to attend college.
Anxious about their future,
pressured by their parents,
and armed with only the most basic
understanding of compound interest,
would-be college freshmen make the kind
of customer most businesses only dream of.
An 18-year-old is more informed about the
brand of shoes they wear than the institution
at which they’ll spend 200 weeks of
their lives and $84,000 on average.
It’s not their fault.
The basic problem is information asymmetry.
Prospective students can take tours, deciding
whether a school’s trees are a satisfactory shade
of green and buildings sufficiently old looking,
but nearly everything else they know
comes from just one source: the seller.
Now imagine making this decision 7,000 miles away,
having never stepped foot in the country,
and as a non-native English speaker.
That’s the challenge faced by America’s
340,000 Chinese international students.
So, what does a diligent
young adult do to compensate?
They turn to the Consumer Reports
of education: college rankings.
But for this prudence,
little do they know, they’re rewarded
with a mix of fraud and deception.
It’s not just that rankings are inaccurate or
misleading — though make no mistake, they are!
The real problem is much, much deeper.
In fact, almost everything wrong with higher
education today — the student loan crisis,
inequitable admissions, academic plagiarism, and
the collapse of tenure are ultimately symptoms.
…Symptoms of one giant,
interconnected web of deceit.
Sponsored by Fabulous, the app
that uses behavioral science
to help you build healthy habits like
meditation, exercise, and better sleep.
From the day a baby is born in China,
he or she unknowingly enters a race.
Although they won’t take the Gaokao, China’s
college entrance exam, for another 18 years,
it alone will ultimately determine
their career and social class.
And “determine” means determine — there are no
letters of recommendation, extracurriculars,
awards, or alternate pathways. The
Gaokao is the only race that matters.
Because it’s held just once a year
and the results highly publicized,
the cost of failure is enormous.
Every hour of sleep lost, every
hobby forgone, and talent abandoned
is easily justified — it could be the
difference between one’s dream and fallback.
Why do Chinese students collectively sacrifice
what the rest of the world calls “adolescence”
for a single exam? In a word: fairness. The
poor farmer’s daughter and chief executive’s
son take the same exam, in the
same room, at the same time.
Of course, in the real world, the rich and
powerful usually find a way. Contradictions,
after all, have never stopped China,
a “Communist” country with the 2nd
highest concentration of billionaires.
For middle and upper-class kids, an overseas
education is a lifeboat on the Titanic — an
escape from academic pressure and
the public spotlight, respectively.
Hong Kong Chief Executive Carrie Lam’s
son and Chairman Xi Jinping’s
daughter both attended Harvard.
Now, hold that thought for a moment.
Seven in ten Americans attend a public college.
But despite coughing up over 21,000 US dollars
a year for in-state tuition, room, and board
on average, students themselves only directly
contribute one-fifth of their school’s budget.
Most of the total — about
40% — is covered by state,
federal, and a bit of local government
grants, contracts, and appropriations.
What this means is that public universities
are largely at the whim of their federal
and state governments, who, in turn,
depend on a healthy stream of tax revenue.
During “normal” times — which is to say, a long
time ago — this was no big deal. The system,
imperfect as it was, chugged along mostly…
fine… enough until the 2008 recession,
when schools were painfully reminded of
the house of cards they’re built upon.
People lost their jobs, the
government lost its tax revenue,
and thus universities lost their funding. Oops.
Not only was there just less money
going around, but because there was
less money going around, universities were
under greater scrutiny to use it well.
Less money, yet more demands.
So what did they do?
What every good Capitalist does, of
course! They commodified education,
casting their line further and further
afield in search of untapped markets.
They both exported the product — slapping
their logos on deep-pocketed modular
architecture everywhere — and imported customers.
International students weren’t some
new invention but universities were
shocked by how deep the wells
were — particularly in China.
It all began as a short-term
solution to an acute problem:
fill a hole in the budget. But
they soon realized the potential.
The intense pressure of the Gaokao, combined with
China’s growing middle-class had produced an
insatiable desire for overseas credentials.
Today, there are two and half times as many
Chinese international students in the U.S.
as second place India, which is itself two
point seven times larger than third place Korea.
And that’s not just because China
is huge. The country is home to 18%
of the world’s population, but 35%
of international students in America.
Demand, in other words, had accidentally
discovered a huge, under-exploited supply.
There was basically no limit to the number
of keen Chinese students they could attract.
Even a decent state school in the middle of
nowhere could arbitrage the American brand,
converting its U.S. address plus the vague notion
of “international exposure” into cold hard cash.
But, say you’re a Chinese student who’s never
stepped foot in the States. How do you pick a
school despite knowing next to nothing about the
country, much less any individual city or state?
You take out your phone, Google “best colleges
in America” and tap on the first result, duh!
Enter college rankings.
Students and their parents are universally
desperate for objective answers — guidance
in making the quote “right choice”, and
later assurance that they indeed have.
Rankings prey on this anxiety, and doubly
so in the case of international students,
whose vacuum of knowledge
is ripe for exploitation.
Chinese international students,
in particular, are both, by far,
the largest kind, and, according to this survey,
the most persuaded by reputation and prestige.
The only little problem is that rankings
are…well, complete and utter garbage.
Let’s start with the low-hanging fruit:
It isn’t possible to reduce an entire
university to a single number. At least, not
without losing all meaning in the process.
In what world does Goshen College,
a Mennonite school with 827 students
in rural Indiana belong on the same list as
a party school, like say, the University of
Alabama, whose student population is
larger than the entire town of Goshen?
In fairness, they do share
the same basic mission — the
proliferation of knowledge. But the
same can’t be said of all schools.
The Mennonites look like close relatives of
Crimson Tide when compared to Peking University
— whose charter replaced “freedom of thought”
with loyalty to the Communist Party in 2019.
One building strives to cultivate
the next generation of thinkers.
The other to churn out obedient workers.
Yet the “big three” international rankings
— QS, ARWU, and The Times — don’t even
acknowledge the fact that entire fields of
study are forbidden at some universities.
But, okay, enough with all
the high-minded philosophy.
At the end of the day, people like to rank things.
And there is an undeniable difference
between your local community college and MIT.
Assuming that schools can be reduced to a single
number, what specific criteria should be used?
You might suggest student
satisfaction, teaching quality,
graduate employment rate, or, how
could you forget, the cost of tuition!
Wrong, wrong, wrong, and lol.
What rankings do consider is the
proportion of international students,
which brings us to the positive feedback loop.
Each new international student increases
their school’s ratio, which, in turn,
boosts its overall ranking. Meanwhile, how
do international students choose schools?
That’s right, rankings!
Around, and around, and around.
At some point, to reject international students is
to willfully forgo prestige, and thereby revenue.
This irresistible self-perpetuating
cycle encourages schools to admit
students even with an inadequate grasp
of English, setting them up to fail.
Schools that pursue this strategy tend to
have very large Chinese student populations,
which often results in “social bubbles” on campus.
After 4 years, they may graduate with few, if any,
local friends, despite coming, in
large part, for that “exposure”.
Now, to put things in perspective, the
international student ratio only comprises 5%
of the QS ranking formula. But make no mistake,
their actual contribution is many times larger.
Few Americans pay the price
of tuition shown on Google.
Those who attend college in their own state
pay only about half the sticker price,
and even out-of-state tuition
is offset by financial aid.
About the only students who do pay full price are
international students. And on top of that, they
pay additional “fees”, disproportionately live
in student dorms, and buy university meal plans.
With all that extra cash, schools
can buy their way up the rankings,
attracting even more students, and so on.
In 2008, Baylor offered new students $1,000
a year in student aid to retake their
SATs and score an extra 50 points,
artificially boosting its numbers.
QS even offers a paid consulting
service, in a clear conflict of interest.
In the best case, this extra cash is
spent hiring more teachers — increasing
its teacher-student ratio, which
comprises 20% of the QS formula,
and attracting researchers, who boost the
school’s academic citations — another 20%.
Now, you might argue that’s how things are
supposed to work. Money affords quality.
The rich get richer — no surprise there, and
there’s no reason schools should all be equal.
But what does “quality” really mean?
Teacher-student ratios tell you
how small a school’s classes are
but not how good the teaching.
Students may wonder why so many of their
classes are capped at 19 or 20 students.
The reason is that U.S. News counts
the number of classes with 20 or fewer.
The result is that access to the
best professors is restricted.
In a world with an infinite number of great
teachers, smaller class sizes would always be
better. But, as anyone who's attended college
can tell you, that’s definitely not the case.
Citations per faculty is an even worse proxy for
quality. The number of academic publications a
school produces has almost nothing to
do with the undergraduate experience.
In fact, more time spent on research
equals less emphasis on teaching.
When folks reminisce about college, they
mention things like the fun social environment
and maybe one or two stand-out classes.
What they don’t tend to remember is their
school’s number of academic citations.
Silly as this sounds, millions of students
inadvertently choose schools
based on this very criteria.
Yet just 2% of admissions directors
think ranking systems are,
quote, “very effective” at helping
students find the right school.
All they really do is reward those willing
to play the game, like Singapore’s NTU — who
made massive leaps in the rankings thanks
to a sudden, coordinated burst of research.
…That’s, of course, assuming the research being
cited is even good. You can probably think of
a widely-cited paper linking vaccines
to a certain… neurological disorder.
Now, you might counter that
students are just holding it wrong,
misunderstanding what rankings
actually measure (research).
But they aren’t even good at measuring that!
A full 50% of the QS formula is reputation.
How does a school gain a “reputation”?
In no small part, rankings!
In other words, rankings measure reputation,
and reputations are determined by ranking.
Professor Imanol Ordorika calls rankings
“Harvardometers” — suggesting they merely
measure how close a school is to what we already
assume to be the best. Any formula that didn’t
place Harvard near the top would have to
go back to the drawing board until it did.
Still, somehow it gets worse. Way worse.
The way reputation is measured is,
in part, with online surveys in which
respondents are rewarded with free “swag”.
U.S. News has college presidents to rate hundreds
of their competitors on a scale of one to five.
In one study, Princeton’s business school was
ranked in the top 10 despite not even existing.
Meanwhile, according to researchers, rankings
aren’t even precise enough to accurately
distinguish between first and tenth place.
The problem is that we act as though they can.
In one egregious case, administrators of
the University of Malaya were fired after
it suddenly dropped 80 places in The Times
ranking due only to a change in definition.
So why not group schools together to at least
avoid giving the false impression of precision?
Because this volatility is a core part of the
rankings business model — it produces an annual
round of drama and publicity. “Wow, this school
dropped 10 places!” and “this one gained 5!”,
when nothing effectively changed
as far as students are concerned.
So. Colleges can’t be reduced to a single number.
Even if they could, this isn’t how you’d do it.
And even if it were, you wouldn’t add
all these different metrics together,
producing a result that neither accurately
measures reputation, quality, or research.
But remember, rankings are not just
a corporate parasite one can ignore.
Imagine if Consumer Reports had a total
monopoly on public information about phones,
TVs, or cars. Apple and Toyota would
design their products not based on what
we actually want but whatever arbitrary metrics
profit-seeking Consumer Reports decides on.
We’ve talked about schools that benefit
from this system. But for every Harvard,
NTU, and Princeton, a dozen more are
held totally captive against their will.
Ranking companies enforce
compliance with a threat:
Either hand over the data we demand,
or your rankings will suffer.
That’s no exaggeration. U.S. News, for instance,
assigns schools who refuse to play
the game below-average scores.
Ultimately, everyone suffers.
Professors are incentivized to
farm citations to keep their
jobs, students are deceived,
international students totally exploited,
and administrators encouraged to cheat.
Yet we all actively play the game. Colleges whose
very professors write papers eviscerating the
methodology of rankings continue advertising
their U.S. News ranking on pamphlets.
Even you, watching this very
video, may intellectually believe
rankings are pointless but will surely close
this window and continue acting otherwise.
It’s a kind of psychological pyramid scheme. Even
if you don’t believe in rankings, you’d be wise
to act as though you do because, real or fake,
they really do mean something to other people.
To justify our crushing student loans and because
you’d be dumb not to advertise the “good” school
you attended, we recruit others — perpetuating
the belief that rankings mean… anything.
But things may be about to change.
Remember: at the heart of all
this were international students.
Just a few short years ago, the rapid growth
of Chinese students on U.S. campuses produced
a mix of both ugly racist anxiety, and
legitimate concerns about academic freedom.
Schools had found a seemingly
bottomless source of income.
To them it felt like an infinite money glitch.
And when every cast of the line is even more
fruitful than the last, even the most rational
fisherman will struggle to restrain themselves.
How could they deliberately leave all this free
money on the table? And besides, if they
don’t catch these fish, someone else will.
Thus, they continued to depend more and
more on Chinese international students,
even while aware of the risk of relying
so heavily on one single market.
Today, the concern is reversed.
When national borders closed in the Spring of 2020
and restrictions extended into summer,
universities began wondering if they had
just permanently lost a critical
component of their revenue model.
The decline in international students doesn’t look
catastrophic. That is, until you focus on
the number of new international students.
Existing students are likely to finish their
degrees no matter what, and because the
decision to take the SAT over the Gaokao, for
instance, is made years in advance in China,
schools still have a few years of runway left.
Students who’ve already committed to this path.
The concern is that, while most of
the world will return to normal,
the largest and most lucrative source
of students, China, never will.
Because, for them, COVID is only
one in an already growing list of
concerns about studying, or even living, abroad.
The Chinese government increasingly portrays
the world beyond its borders as a violent,
unwelcoming, apocalyptic wasteland,
seizing on every legitimately tragic crime in
order to tell a larger story of state collapse.
The number one criteria for choosing
a school is not teaching quality,
career prospects, or even
cost of living. It’s, by far,
“safety”. And international students
have never felt less safe in America.
What does it mean for higher education
that a central feature of their business,
academic, and incentive structure
may be permanently disrupted?
That their largest source of revenue
may suddenly be gone forever?
How will they compensate when this wasteful,
inefficient, system also
becomes financially insolvent?
The truth is no one yet knows. Not even they do.
Some argue the “university” model is in
decline and will soon be replaced with
mass online education. But schools
still have one giant advantage:
Anything can be learned online, but only schools
can offer accountability, structure, and guidance.
That’s also the premise behind Fabulous,
today’s sponsor. Fabulous is a habit-forming
and tracking app backed by science.
You don’t need an app to meditate, get
better sleep, or be more productive,
but most of us, myself included, need motivation
and accountability to do so consistently.
You pick the healthy habits and Fabulous
will help you actually stick to them.
What I like about the app is that it adjusts to
you. They know you’ll resist anything that feels
like homework. So, instead, the app learns
when and how to remind and motivate you.
I used to run 7 days a week, 52 weeks a year, but
kina accidentally took this last year or so off.
I’ve been using Fabulous for over a month now
and am back to exercising three times a week.
Start building your ideal daily routine!
The first 500 people who click the link
on screen now or in the description
will get 25% off Fabulous Premium.